lena ich bin so froh dass du gekommen
ist ehrlich ich war blöd zu dir
es tut mir leid könne in ordnung
ich fand es nur komisch dass wir uns so
gar nicht mehr gesehen haben
aber sag mal deine kader ist wirklich
die kanadier mit mark zusammen
seine ex freundin ja unglaublich oder
aber ich glaube das ist kein gutes thema
hat der alltag ist ganz komisch wenn ich
über sie rede
ich finde das eher komisch dass er sich
mit dem taxi von der uni abholen wollte
ja das hat mich auch überrascht sehr
sehr nett aber das bin ich auch
schließlich habe ich dich zum essen
eingeladen und es gibt nicht nur
leckeres essen sondern na ja ich habe
mir gedacht würde sich freuen wenn diese
etwas mehr kennen werden
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich überhaupt
das würde dir schon zeigen das huhn
und jetzt dürfen wir so lange nicht die
küche bis die beiden fertig sind
du kannst es kaum erwarten lena sehr
angetan hätte sie schon
vielleicht solltest du etwas mutiger
sein
nicht so schön so besser ist und groß
mal wieder was na klar
motto wie du mir nie verstehen also wenn
ich es versuchen würde was ich natürlich
nicht tue
das kommt jetzt noch mal in den ofen
damit das waren app werden wie die
vorspeisen essen
so etwas habe ich noch nie gegessen den
plastischen gruppen joghurt nein das
huhn mit
das wird lecker ich verspreche es dir
und außerdem ist das ein aphrodisiakum
du meinst du einen tag mit dem man jedem
in rom krediten aber erst genau